I took some time to reflect on the
importance of mental health and how
isolating it can feel when you're
struggling I want others to realize that
you're not alone and it does get better
during this month let's take a sec and
reflect each day
having peace and knowing it's okay to
not be okay
I'm on a mission to shed light on this
affliction
and this is not an intervention just
please sit down and listen
when we wrestle with ourselves it's not
about ability it's about coming to grips
with the list of our fragilities
no person should feel isolated for any
amount of time nevertheless don't let
loneliness Define your state of mind
do not tuck these thoughts deep down
away and hide I've been there but like
Adele I'm saying hello from the other
side for my jobs to relationships
even violence in the U.S our finances
how inflation hits
Frozen in fear on what we do next
this thing called life is harder than
what we grew up thinking
but if you no longer attempt to stay
afloat that only means that you're
sinking
like a ship dropping an anchor I just
hope that sinks in
things may seem Bleak on weekdays but
that can all change by the weekend
I'm here to tell you that it does get
better the trick is to appreciate the
temperature no matter the weather even
when it feels like a dark cloud up above
but if it can rain pain then it can Rain
Love
easiest thing is to give up and say why
Try
especially when it's so hard to make
real connections like Wi-Fi I try to
plug into the proper Source when you're
feeling depleted
remember you woke up today
step one completed you succeeded so
let's keep this conversation going and
talk together
this is our parade to Greater days
so let's walk together
that is great thank you can you be bad
at something please
what are you doing this weekend no what
did you ask him what do you do this
weekend building a spice rack for your
wife like I just I just wanted to offer
a little bit to this series which was
you know give some perspective on how I
look at mental health and I love to
write it's therapy for me I mean I just
hope it it brings brighter days for
someone that might be struggling that's
very hard to do there's a lot of
surprising turns in there a really true
turn to phrase and a lot of wisdom too
thank you brother I appreciate that what
did you say one step at a time I like
what you said about the weekend oh yeah
it could seem Bleak on weekdays bit
better but it can all change by the
weekend but weekdays is also week as in
WEA yeah yeah